it wasn't until I think we did like 17
million in ebitda like profit take home
my dad called me and he's like are you
sitting down I remember like at this
point like we were like not talking too
much he was like I'm sorry and it was
the first time he'd ever apologized to
me in my life what's interesting to me
though is that it didn't feel like
anything because I had stopped caring
about what he thought about me a long
time ago when I quit my job was the day
that like I accepted dying to my father
pretty much to me at that point was I
had really done everything that he had
wanted me I finished Vanderbilt in three
years president of fraternity had won
writing Awards I'd done everything it
wasn't enough and I knew that the choice
for me was that I either had to die to
him or I had to die to myself wow when
he called me and he apologized and this
is where I like you know I'm ashamed of
myself I could have just let it lie
instead I said I was like you know when
people get up on stage like hey Mom and
Dad I just want to say thanks so much
for always believing me I was like I
won't say that oh my God what do you say
to that he said well we'll see how long
it lasts